now Christmas is one of the most magical
times of the year in large part down to
a certain portly character with a beard
and a red suit no not calling on a
Sunday and Gatos up and down the country
farmer Christmas is doing his best to
bring joy to children and bring that
magic to their lives and if any young
children are watching right now mom dad
I find you make to turn the body and
down for this next part so what can you
expect him when Santa meets your lovely
children were here to discuss this is
the UK's very best Santa Claus I'm Nigel
Harvey morning I feel first of all that
I'm the envy of many children here
because it's bringing kids to work day
outside in this glass spot it's got lots
of children coming there waving it to
you of course and I've been ambushed
since I got here it's terrific Grinch I
take father Christmas away from the kids
who I can speak to them personally yes
it's funny it's usually the mummies and
want to talk to father Christmas is
rather odd really diamond rings yes what
would you like for Christmas you would
like something like that
well I've sent you my list I thought I
was in the good pile do you do not know
what I want it's not that I made two of
them just a moment ago well yeah I know
I know this is what I love about you
wanting diamond rings though you always
were deluded even as a little girl well
tell us how is it you get the title of
UK's best Santa Claus would you have to
do to get that well I know I wouldn't
say I have the best probably the best in
my price range and I don't know well the
thing is it's about making the character
real it's about one foot in reality one
foot in magic and there's some terrific
Santa's helpers out there that do that
but it's about making it real I think
because the internet and TV there's so
many people out there saying I don't
exist well quite honestly I do and I
always have and always will
it's about the experience you give to
children because as I say the kids here
have just lit up just seeing your face
so so what is the difference between a
good father Christmas making sure
they've got something that will last the
rest of their lives even when you know
the reality of it just hits them maybe
when they when they get a bit older I
think we're a lot of corporate grottoes
go wrong is they spend a fortune on the
grotto
and then put someone in on minimum wage
in a fancy dress costume that doesn't
want to be there anymore the thing is if
you want a good Santa you have to pay
get a proper actor than is what they're
doing that can make that character real
and give children something to believe
in and if you do then want to pay that
extra buck what could you offer them
what what could a good father Christmas
getting the right salary for the job
what would you have to give them
compared to a minimum wage father Chris
well the thing is you need to research
about father Christmas and Saint
Nicholas and so any questions you can
answer you know you need to know all the
names of the reindeers you need to know
things that are happening at the moment
like at the moment with brexit we've got
the the brexit Christmas dinner that has
doesn't have any brussels little joe
little quips like that people like yes
yes I know but you're right well the
Christmas because it has it's been a
pretty tough year lot lot going on a lot
of depressing things in the news that we
cover all the time I mean how important
is it maybe take Children and Families
away from that well a bit of escapism is
terrific I mean that the thing is as you
say so many bad things going on in the
world now if you can just make people
lose themselves even for a couple of
moments it is worth it and I've seen a
lot of very terminally ill children this
year and you're bringing joy and magic
of the darkest moments and it's or they
can be very difficult it's also very
rewarding because you could know you can
see a child that's in a lot of pain and
they're giggling with laughter or you
know and money can't buy that so it's
all about being able to spread joy I
mean like Colin does the rest of the
year I just I'm just this idea of you
know speaking the language of father
Christmas he was a fourth century Greek
bishop how-how's you're Greek well yes
but the thing is we've got a long way
from there you need to get with the
times
Colin you really do I mean come on
you've had more children than most
well that is a problem it is a problem
and they've been there open a case I've
been days on the run to Christmas yes
where they've seen multiple father
Christmas's yes and it's for you just
sort of square that logically with them
I don't like you we'll all come up we
all become complicit don't we yes after
something go you've got to tell these
little white lies now they're not white
lies the thing is Santa does exist and
if you see more than one Santa it's
Santa's dipping in and out of timelines
surely you watch Doctor Who she'll you
understand rival Channel father
Christmas I don't bring myself exactly I
have to I have to be able to slow down
time like Christmas even it seems to
take a lot longer it's a bit like
watching one of your interviews just
spiky how long how long does it take you
to get to the full fig this takes me
about an hour right the chap underneath
it looks completely different sounds
nothing like this and it's great because
he can after a gig can walk out and no
one bat an eyelid so it's it really is
terrific and it's you know it's it's
been wonderful for this particular
actually this Nigel Harvey chap because
he now gets to do this all year round
all year at all year round because I how
does that work well because you have TV
companies and advertising companies
doing things out of sync I mean I filmed
a Christmas special that comes out in
December on the 5th of January so it's
still constantly going and even I get
invited to do summer Santa at some of
the festivals Santa on vacation now what
it will be doing is promoting something
that's happening at Christmas but if you
have hashtag summer Santa with me my
summer gear you get discounted tickets
and so on and so forth you must see the
full range of children I mean you know
kids who are really grateful
yes very obedient yes and some brats yes
I mean how do you how do you treat them
all fairly well the thing is
brats usually have they've got too
clever comments to make now if you've
got a clever comment to come back it's
sort of shuts them up pretty quick but
your old school entertainment argue in a
sense you know you're not social media
you notice I'm finding you more
entertaining than Facebook but maybe
there are kids who don't I mean you've
got rivals out there haven't you to keep
their attention even yes absolutely but
the thing is you cannot beat one-on-one
meeting someone and you know if people
say oh don't meet your heroes you have
it disappoints us what I try and do is
make it better than they imagined so
it's even more magical is even more
wonderful than what they were
anticipating what about the older kids
then that gives you a fighting going to
say social media so I've got a 12 year
old and a four year old it's very
difficult to get my 12 year old to get
in on the act
but it makes a difference right we've
got a good father Christmas to hopefully
just bring that little child back the
thing is when I th a see me they get it
straightaway
and I've had teenagers coming coming up
begging for selfies and I've met the
real father here without any selfies you
can persuade that exactly but I think
teenagers especially when they see you
doing it properly they go oh hang on a
minute this is someone with the cotton
wool stuck on its face you know we've
got we've got something real happening
here later to see how really it is how
do you how do you stop yourself becoming
bored with the role I mean you know
you're an actor yeah part of acting is
the variety of all the roles and
learning the different scripts etc
you've only got the one script the one
character but I haven't got one script
because a child could come and ask you
something completely random such as it's
a well for instance you know you can
have a child say so what does mrs. Claus
wear embed things like that you like
well let me just check that it's not
quite watershed yet applause yes well
you see obviously I I say well she wears
she wears a a dressing gown because it's
so very cold in the north ho you see
what's it like when you when you see
children responding and reacting to you
the thing is really a child get excited
I get
excited as well so both get lost in the
moment and the thing is a lot of
grown-ups that have not really had a
good Santa experience in their childhood
suddenly they become children as well
and they get excited so it's all about
tapping into that that joy because there
is joy to be had and just with a few
choice words here and there it's such a
powerful character you could make
someone's year even if it had a terrible
year I've had I've had elderly women
come up to me in tears saying it took me
took me to the age 80 before I met
father Christmas and they they've got
tears in their eyes so if you would do
it right you know the rewards are just
endless this full-time for Nigel then
there's no I don't have to do anything
else or it just all can he just be
father Christmas 24 but Nigel wanted to
do lots of things acting wise but the
phone rings and they go can stand to do
this and can stand to do that so it's
sort of you know he he certainly thought
when he first happened well that's
December sorted out he didn't realize if
he asked to do things and also I've been
asked by the Sancta community to go and
do keynote speeches of big Santa
community yes there's a whole community
out there so you know the internet is
good for some things my wife is on one
level that the the the grittiest least
sentimental woman I've ever met but she
gives Gaga about Christmas I I remain a
little bit agnostic what do you say -
bah humbug Scrooge types like me that we
should suspend our disbelief and and get
with the Santa program well the thing is
I mean from what I remember you as a
child you've never been so it's
something this happens what's wrong in
life you know and everyone gets a little
bit grumpy I mean even I get grumpy
father Christmas has off days you know
and but what I get or I can say is look
there's so much negativity out there
there's so many things in life that are
very bad if you've got a reason to
celebrate do it because oh I'm not
celebrating my birthday I'm not
celebrating Christmas they're probably
the two times of the year
that you're going to have the
opportunity to celebrate that's two out
of 365 days enjoy it because you know
I'm sure as everyone out there you know
I've lost dear ones this this year and
so Christmas is going to be someone
missing so you never know every
opportunity you have to enjoy something
do it because you can't turn back time
and have a better time of wish I had
done this which I'd done that Christmas
and birthdays celebrate wedding
anniversaries celebrates just a she was
a semi a semi serious point nine hundred
thousand people this Christmas Day will
be working now it's fair enough if
you're one of those journalists have
always worked in Christmas Day but lots
of people now have to cook other
people's meals which strikes me as a bit
bah humbug really more in all of us are
working on Christmas Day you know making
it less special
well yes I get that and in some cases
people have to work Christmas Day to
make ends meet because because of the
situation that we're in but certainly at
some point during the day if you can
just have that moment to just take a
deep breath and just enjoy it because
you know I mean look what what look
what's just happened recently in Germany
you would never know what's around the
corner any opportunity please please
please grab it by both hands and have a
good time for Christmas Eve since since
forever right yes it's made my life very
enjoyable I can tell you it's been
wonderful okay well I'm gonna speak to
you a little bit later about like that
list I spoke to you about earlier
Holly thanks very much clearly so I got
my photo the ready for the selfie I'm
gonna just a little Tuggle those
whiskers oh really